so here is a pramas rally in Brooklyn
New York Brooklyn New York which of
course is home to one of the largest
populations of Jews in the United States
and they're calling for River to the Sea
which is a genoz chant and a bunch more
and the New York City Police Department
which is which is certainly not the NYPD
of old of the old days right this is not
Rudy giuliani's NYPD these are these are
largely good people who are trying many
of them have retired early uh many of
them have now been brought down to
Florida because Dan santis has said to
these guys hey if you don't want to work
there and you're good and you're decent
we'll we'll take you down here so one of
the other things happening right now is
that the blue states are losing their
good police officers because the
administrations don't back them this is
a problem uh it got a little violent in
uh in Brooklyn with the pro Hamas and by
the way I have no problem calling these
people Pro Hamas protesters people keep
saying well they're not all for Hamas I
have yet to see anyone literally one
person at any of these rallies that is
out there with the sign I'm for the
gazin but I am against Hamas right these
all of these things all of these
protests broke out after Hamas killed
about 1,400 Israelis and still have 200
uh hostages including about a dozen
Americans which nobody seems to care
about anyway here's Brooklyn uh just in
the last day or
[Music]
[Applause]
two
I got to say the police are trying they
are trying to let people peacefully
protest uh one of the things that we are
going to be challenged on going forward
constantly is what are the limits of
free speech if you are chanting for
genocide how close does that get to a
direct threat of violence if you are
targeting as they've done in London
repeatedly now uh if you target just a
random store owned by a Jew for your
anti-israel supposed protest are you
infringing on the rights of that person
to own their store right to basically
run a business and we know this thing is
far more than anger over Israel's
response to what happened in southern
Israel right this was all coordinated it
was all ready just think back to BLM
they turn this thing on when they want
and they turn it off when they don't
want and by the way that is deeply
connected to George Soros and the people
who fund all of these organizations
right BLM was funded to the tunes of
hundreds hundreds of millions of dollars
if not billions of dollars did they send
one black kid to college we could do a
little research on that did they open
one black shop did they do anything
about urban renewal in Black communities
or did they just get a bunch of people a
bunch of grifters real
rich